nicki morgan we learned this morning
that this man wayne cousins
was assigned to the house of commons to
guard
mps
of which you would have been one um
what's your reaction to discovering that
well good morning trevor um well my
reaction to to that actually is that um
of course it's a it's a development in
the story but actually this is not about
parliament this is not about um the
guarding of uh of parliament there's
always an issue about vetting i know
you've been talking to other guests
about that but i really hope we don't
make this about parliament um because
actually this is about the safety of
women and girls across the country many
of whom don't work in a very protective
place like parliament and westminster
and many of whom do uh exactly what
sarah everard does and they did and they
they do it every day which is to walk
somewhere home decide perhaps not to get
a bus to go for a run
um and if they were stopped by a police
officer perhaps until last week they
would have done what they were asked to
do um now of course that relationship of
trust between the police and i think
many women and girls in this country is
teetering on a knife edge and there's a
a lot of work for the police uh to do
and i think we need to concentrate on
that rather than this development about
parliament it may well turn out he's
guarded other places too we just don't
know but actually it's about the safety
of women and girls like sarah everard
palm sanders just suggested that every
police officer
should be
re-vetted
would you agree with that
well i would agree with that um and i
think as your other some of your other
guests have said already this is um a
much broader cultural issue i mean it's
kind of inevitable that we are this
morning talking about whether it's
vetting
or we're talking about how exactly uh
wayne cousins got to the position that
he was in was able to move forces and of
course that has got to be looked at but
there's also a broader cultural issue i
think what palm sound is just saying
it's not it's in it's in all workplaces
actually it's in
all organizations and it's on our
streets as well whereby it is just
appalling and unacceptable that women
and girls do not feel safe when they are
walking around often in broad daylight
that's a cultural issue and that's a
cultural issue that the police have
absolutely got to get to grips with and
frankly that's the test for cressida
dick you know
i'd like to hear from her a plan about
how she is going to tackle
changing the culture in the met and
actually from all the other potential
chief constables as well now at that
point that's the test for whether she
keeps the job or not
let's address this wider cultural issue
one aspect of this is who should be
responsible for
fixing the problem as it were well we've
heard
the reaction for example to the
met advice that women should wave down a
bus i don't think we need to detain
ourselves on that but more
importantly i suppose i talked a little
earlier on to party chairman about the
remarks of the north yorkshire
police and crime commissioner who said
that women need to be streetwise about
when they can be arrested and when they
can't be arrested
oliver dowden said he and the prime
minister were outraged but i don't think
they were outraged enough to say this
person should be should not be a member
of the conservative party what do you
think
well i mean i have to say i think they
were incredibly stupid remarks um and
they were delivered by somebody who
clearly has never been in a situation
where they have walked down a street and
heard footsteps behind them and wondered
uh you know what's going to happen in
the next couple of minutes
uh got the keys out their bags in order
to be able to uh to defend themselves if
they if they have to um and frankly for
a police and crime commissioner to
basically hint that actually um women
need to be more uh aware um about uh
more skeptical actually if a police
officer stops them um i think is is
frankly uh extraordinary
um i mean i have to i'm not in favor i
mean i hope that um that philip outlet
has been uh contacted by whether it's
the party chairman whether it's the home
secretary whether it's the prime
minister and asked to explain himself um
and you know again at the end of the day
if somebody senior has said something or
not done something i would rather they
actually admitted a mayor cooper i've
got this wrong here's my plan for doing
it
rather than you know throwing people out
of the party or or getting them to
resign uh imminently so i think we
better hear from mr allen what his plan
is and if i were a woman in his police
and uh a crime kushner area then i would
want to hear from him what his plan is
actually make women feel safer when
they're going about their lives
but i suppose what i'm really uh trying
to get at here is that this is an
example of what i think you would say
you would describe as part of the
cultural problem that actually
the the big issue andy burnham talked
about this uh uh a moment ago the big
issue here is
not that women need to fix this but
there needs to be something uh about the
way that men behave now one of the
things we've heard about in this week is
the locker room
culture
that female police officers describe
one of the reasons that you left the
house of commons is that
you said that
you got lots of abuse and we know that
women mps are more likely to get abuse
uh and be undermined than male mps do
you think we can do anything about this
kind of culture
uh yeah i i do think we can do something
uh about it um and i know that there is
a huge determination amongst uh
ministers amongst the uh speaker of the
house of commons for example to tackle
um online abuse of members of parliament
but also uh actually the the new
elections bill proposes um
makes proposals about the intimidation
of candidates for example but you're
absolutely right trevor this is a wider
broader problem that has gone un-um
untested for or unchallenged for far too
long and of course as well as being uh
minister for women equalities a few
years ago i was also education secretary
and i heard what andy burnham said and i
think he is correct to say that actually
this is um also a challenge for men to
to call out when they hear unacceptable
language or so-called banter being used
but actually it starts right away at
schools and
the pshe curriculum the uh is so
important in what it teaches uh both
boys and girls about respect for
themselves about about issues about uh
consent about the language that we use
um you know when i was education
secretary i talked a lot about character
that's also about thinking about the
impact that you're having on people uh
around you wanting to do the right thing
even when somebody is not looking all of
that and then of course oliver dowden
also rightly highlighted
and again as a former culture secretary
the impact that the online harms bill
will need to have about making sure
because sadly a lot of abuse i suffered
and others suffer i think is absolutely
fueled by the misogyny that is allowed
to go rampant on our social media
platforms
actually that bill will be very
important again in beginning to change
the culture of those platforms make
those tech companies accountable for
what's on there getting that content off
and saying being transparent about how
they do that and of course policing that
to make sure they are doing what they
say they're going to to protect the
users of those platforms
indeed just very briefly of course
at the center of this is still the issue
of
uh the way that
women are spoken about and regard and so
on and this is a non-partisan point when
harriet harman was in government
there were things said about her
you know obsessed by women's issues and
so on and we we see to some extent
the
treatment of uh liz truss and pretty
patel
do you think that actually
there is a problem in
politics that
prominent women are not spoken about or
regarded in the same way as prominent
men
i don't think it's universal but i think
a lot of the coverage
of women in politics still focuses far
too much on obviously um what we are uh
how we are presenting rather than what
we are actually saying i mean i think we
remember that picture do you remember of
theresa may nicolas sturgeon when they
first met and that you know that picture
of them sitting there and i think was
more commentary about their knees being
on show than what they actually said in
their meeting and of course i remember
walking down downing street um and
somewhere there's a very unattractive
picture of me
and uh because i was walking down
without my rod and the photographer
shouted out girls girls and i was like
no girls we are secretaries of state and
i think absolutely the language that
people use as i say about all of us um
people in public life generally
obviously matters and again we all have
to think about that at at all times it
is much better than i think it it was uh
but there's always room to prove not
just in westminster in all organizations
and of course the spotlight is very
firmly on our police forces at the
moment